you're more likely to fail at marriage
than succeed and I thought about this
okay yeah what's the general reputation
of marriage pretty awful yeah negative
right it's not it's not a good thing
right yeah I'm not saying it can't ever
be a good thing but just by and large
it's like a lot of times what I see them
do is they'll blame everyone else for
marriage is reputation I didn't create
the society yeah I didn't so it's not
our fault for talking about it so when I
thought about okay if we take 50 of
marriages fail and then we take the
other 50 and how if if there's a
negative reputation we can assume at
least half of those are unhappy which
isn't something that we would strive for
right then you could argue 75 failure
rate meaning you're more likely to fail
than succeed why is that the path to
happiness